you know what would make your kids  really jealous what's that is if you  just pose with a lightsaber with thin  that would actually make them very  gently  - it I've got one I've got one in  Manchester United red where is it you  know I really do I really do where's the  blue one again okay there's the blue one  and actually now here's the thing  because you're in is that you're in the  new King Arthur film I am just a small  part yeah have you done some sort  training ah I have done some no look at  him look at this okay  you get that to work Hill can we not  kill Kylie now there's a whip so  basically to turn this on you push you  push that thing that one up okay oh  you've got on David Beckham you've got  off met your match I just wanted to meet  you make  Oh  just like me I've just been constant  starwars he was just like all right mate  don't in the comments you know oh yeah  whatever blood one of the blur blur blur  get down to this one mr. David Beckham  that's my jumper